عيون وعشاق الموضه والازياء مسلط على
باريس في هذه الايام انه اسبوع الموضه
الاشهر في العالم اسبوع شهد العديد من
الاحداث والمنافسه ولعل ابرز مكان في ظهور
العديد من الاتجاهات الغريبه عشرات دور
الازياء الكبرى عالميا قدمت مجموعات
ابتسمت بالفخامه والاناقه والابتكار في
معرض الدار كرستيانور مجموعتها الجديده
للخياطه الرفيعه لهذا العام بعرض مستوحه
من تاريخ بيكر حيث كان زميل ليس ساري
حاضرا واعد تقريرا ثاني
[موسيقى]
في ساحه متحف هدى البارقسيه العريق
فهي كانت مغنيه وراقصه امريكيه من اصل
افريقي انتقلت من الولايات المتحده في
منتصف عشرينيات القرن الماضي الى باريس
العصريه التي كانت وجهه حالمه للفنانين
في مرحله ما بعد الحرب وقدمت عروض على
مسرح وفي قاعه كاملين في نيويورك وفي قاعه
كارناجيل في نيويورك
الفرنسيه على غرار
[موسيقى]
وماسنجر
ده الموسم قطع حيكه من الحرير والمخمل
بتاثير المتجعد وايقاع المتسامل مضيفا على
القماش لمسه نابضه بالحيويه اما التطريز
فاتسم بطابع مرهف تنتشر الازرار الفضيه
والترتر على التصاميم كما رافقت الشراريب
الفضيه والذهبيه بعد قطع المجموعه
والبدلات والمعاطف بالاقمشه الرجاليه التي
لا طالما احبها الراحل كريستيان ديور
شاركت الارض وتميزت القطع والسفليه
للاطلالات بطولا يصل الى فوق الكاحل العين
كاشفه عن احذيه عاليه الكعبه بن عالم جريء
[موسيقى]
سبايدر سبايدر
مان
[موسيقى]
العميق لهذه المشكله
نذهب معكم الى ليس بازاري مراسل صباح
العربيه من باريس
يسعد هالصباح يا ليث
يا ليث يسعد صباحك
مشاهير العالم
ههه
لا لا اسمعت والله سمعت السؤال اسمع
الدليل واحد هيك باخذ شويه صمت على كل حال
عجبني كثير قبل شوي من اهم الملفات الي
شفتها بصباح العربيه موضوع الديمقراطي او
الشيخ شيخوخه شفنا قبل شوي كثير رائع بدنا
نحكي عن خلينا نبدا بالاسبوع الازياء
هالمره نحكي عن الدعوات حضور اسبوع
الازياء عادتها بتكون عباره عن بطاقه مثل
ما بتشوفها مثلا دعوه الجور او ممكن تكون
عباره عن دوسيه او ملف مثل استفهام ولكن
كبريللي طبعا المصمم دانيال روزماري اتفضل
انها تكون هيك الدعوه عباره عن قطعه
معدنيه ذهنيه وهي عن قناع اذا شفنا ثقيله
شويه
انه شيء غريب حتى العرض يتذكر هذا الاسد
مع كالي جونير كيف كان الموضوع
المميز عروض الاجزاء
هذا الموسم
شده البرد في باريس شيء طبيعي المش طبيعي
تشوفه انه سيدات الجميلات اللي بيجوا على
عروض الازياء بيذان او في بيكون حافل
صغيره خاصه طبعا قزاز اسود من شان ما حدا
يعرفهم لانه البعض منهم طبعا مشهورين
بتلاقيهم اول ما ينزلوا من هالفان مع انها
الدنيا برد وساعات الصباح بتكون كثير
بارده في اوروبا وخصوصا بفرنسا بتلاقيها
بالشارع معطف وبالبس الفستان الي قد يكون
يعني اكيد تصميم جميل
وتحملوا البريد مشان بس يكونوا قدام
المصورين عدسات الفوتوغراف او المصورين
يلتقطوا الصور وتنشر في المجلات هذا طبعا
كثير همم صدمني انه يعني بفضل الواحد يضحي
هلا بعرف الواحد بيضحي للازياء بس مش
لهالدرجه انها تكون لدرجه انه الواحد
يتحمل هالبلد القارس هذا المحصل في بعض
العروض هنا في باريس واذا حكينا عن الحضور
المشاهير الجدد واقعد بقصد بالمشاهير
الجدد اللي هما يوتيوبرز بلوجرز بلوجرز
وغيرهم يعني شفنا في واحد مشهور صانع
محتوى على في فرنسا اسمه كريزي شفناها خطف
الاضواء تخيلوا من مين من روجر فيديرير او
روجيه فيرير سويسرا لاعب التنس حتى يكون
يعني كثير ناس مره وانا متاكد في عرض
ازياء ديور في ميزان شفناها قبل شوي كثير
ناس مروا من جنب ما عرفوه
بالضبط وانا كمان الاستغربت انه صار في
جيل جديد شفنا لاشخاص من تيك توك فرنسيين
وغيرهم شفنا ناس من المانيا كمان اجوا
وصلوا على على العروض الازياء والصريخ
الجيل الشعب الي كان موجود خارج عروض
الازياء كانوا يهتفوا باسامي الاشخاص
بصراحه في منهم ما كنت اعرفهم تعرفت عليهم
ولا ما سمعت اللي هتافات بره عرفت انهم
السوري
الفرق بي تي اس مثلا
وهمم اليوم كمان ليث بدنا نسالك على
مشاركه الذكور والاناث معا همم
فاشن شود لالي صعب
همم نادين هاي كانت الظاهره موجوده كنا
نشوفها كثير بعروض
شولي او ماديا جرانس لما كانوا يقعدوا
لدار فالنتينو بس هلا زادت يعني بعرض
ازياء الي صعب المستوحى من الحضاره
التايلانديه شفنا سبعه لوكس او اربع مظاهر
لشباب شاركوا ومش اول مره الي صعب قبل
هالفتره الموسم قبل هذا الموسم برده شارك
همم ثلاث عارضين رجال هذه صارت كثير همم
على موت او على الموضه نشوف هاي الاشياء
المشاركه للرجال اكثر همم يعني دمج في
عروض الازياء او الخياطه الرفيعه بتعرفوا
في عرضين ازياء الرجالي
يناير وبشهر يونيو وبشهر سته بس هلا برضه
صارت المشاركه وشغل الثانيه
يعني صناع السينما المخرجيين شفنا كلود
لوش المخرج الفرنسي الشهير موجود في عروض
الازياء في عرض السفر رينو شفنا كمان
ايزابيلاج جاني كاتخندناف برده هم طبعا من
نجوم السلامه الفرنسيه شفناهم برضو في
عروض الازياء هذا الموسم في عندي ديور
وشفنا قبل هالمره لاعبين فوتبول انا اذكر
تماما نيمار كان يشارك في بلما شفنا كمان
همم دانيال دانيال الفيش كان يشارك شفناها
برده مره عند زهير مراد شفنا كمان مين
كمان اريد كونتونا لاعب الفوتبول الفرنسي
القديم شفناه بلونفا برده صار يعني همم
يشد ناس ما لهم علاقه بالازياء فقط وهي
منصه حتى يبينها الاشخاص اللي بيكون عاده
عليها من الاضواء خصوصا
عالم الازياء وعالم الموضه وطبعا اذا
حكينا بدنا نرجع نحكي عن اصدقاء اشواق
النجوم كوريا يعني شكرا من بلاك بينك
موجود جيزو من بي تي اس
طبعا نعم
فالنتينا امبارح بالليل متاخر برده كان
واحد منهم برده موجود فصاروا حتى الدور
الازياء يستقط بها المشاهير الغناء اذا
صحت تعبير العروض الاجزاء حتى يكون
اكسلوجر حتى يكون اكثر همم الاضواء على
اعمالهم الفنيه
من تصميم ازياء من خلال هؤلاء المشاهير
همم المشاهير الفن والغناء واذا حكينا
طبعا والاسد طبعا كيالي وعرض ازياء همم
شفنا كيف انه يعني هذه طريقه العرض الغريب
اذا صح التعبير فساتين ان كانت باشكال
حيوانات وباشكال ثاني قد تكون مستوحاه مره
باذكر عرض نسيت لاي دار قبل موسمين كان
مستوحه من عالم السيارات كانت كل سيده
ترتدي فستان وكانه سياره نوع من الانواع
السيارات يعني صرنا يعني بعدين ال ال ال
عالم الاجزاء صار يعودوا اكثر الى سبعنيات
القرن الماضي هذا شفناه بعرض ازياء امبارح
بالليل زهير مراد عندما عمل من سبعينيات
القرن الماضي في همم او شالوب فرنسا كيف
كانت ترتدي السيده هذا الموسم وكثير من
الدور الازياء لفتني كمان مره انه صاروا
يرجع كثير لسبع ايام القرن الماضي للخزانه
القديمه للازياء حتى يستوحي عروض ازيائهم
ان شاء الله بالعروض المقبله انا وسهام
نكون برفقتك هتشوف التسويق الهجوم
للجماهير ههه شكرا جزيلا يا ليث
انتم لا تعليق انا شاهدت مجروحه فيكم انتم
دائما بتنسقوا مشالله عليكم